[Laughter]
hello everyone welcome to the active
inference lab this is active inference
live stream number 31.0
it's october 14 2021.
welcome to the act imp lab we are a
participatory online lab that is
communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at the links here on this slide
this is recorded in an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and we'll be following good
video etiquette for live streams
at this short link you can see some of
the past present and future
streams that we'll be doing in the lab
as part of the dot com's organizational
unit and the first tab has the regular
tuesday discussions that are group
discussions dot one and dot two
right now we're in a dot zero kind of an
ad hoc scheduled contextualizing live
stream
and then the other tabs have other kinds
of live streams that can be scheduled at
different times different topics so just
let us know if you want to get involved
or co-organize an event with us
today in active stream number 31.0
the goal is to learn and discuss
this paper non-equilibrium
thermodynamics and the free energy
principle in biology by patricia
palacios and matteo colombo
like all the dot zeros you'll get the
disclaimer that this is just an
introduction to some of the ideas of the
paper and the context it's not a review
or a judgment or a final word
in
31.0 we're going to start by looking
over some of the key aims and claims and
the abstract and the roadmap of the
paper to get the big picture
then talk about some of the keywords
maybe you're really familiar with some
of the keywords maybe it's the first
time you've thought about some of these
topics and then we'll walk through some
of the figures and formalisms and just
get set up in the coming weeks to be
discussing this paper
so we'll start with just some
introductions and warm-ups we'll say
hello and then maybe just mention
something that we're excited to
talk about or learn about or something
that we noticed while reading the paper
so i'm daniel i'm a researcher in
california and this is just an exciting
paper and topic because it's at the
intersection of chemistry and physics
and thermodynamics but also active
inference and it's a nice
starting point for a conversation about
what are the precursors and the tenants
and the principles of free energy
principle and active inference and then
what are the consequences and what does
that mean for the big picture blue
i'm blue knight i'm an independent
research consultant in new mexico uh and
i really was excited to see this paper
bring up some of the points that i've
brought up as i've been reading more
about active inference
specifically with uh respect to
ergodicity and
what that means the potential
implications for that
and also just other minor topics but
things i've mentioned in the past
it's cool sometimes to see how the
threads of our previous discussions and
things that
a participant might have brought up like
hey this isn't making sense and it's
like don't worry it's not just you these
are open
research questions and so we're seeing
that and we'll be enacting it in the
coming weeks
some of the big questions in the paper
kind of framed in
non-technical or in not the author's
words
it's really asking what fundamental
ideas from physics are utilized in the
free energy principle and how are they
utilized why are they utilized and then
what are some implications or trade-offs
associated with the use of these ideas
either the ways that they have been used
what are the pros and cons or what are
the implications and what about the ways
that they could be used
so in the spirit of
positive contributions to the literature
how are we taking ideas from physics and
other fields
bringing it together in free energy
principle and then what are the
fundamental or just spuriously
contemporary tradeoffs
let's first go to the aims and claims of
the authors
so
all read it and then blue you can give a
thought
well the paper is the non-equilibrium
thermodynamics and free energy principle
in biology on the fillsci archive at
pitt so check out the paper and read it
if you want to
and a few of their aims and claims that
we can extract out
the free energy principle has received a
lot of attention but its foundations in
statistical physics and dynamical
systems theory have not been probed yet
this lack of attention is unfortunate
because the theoretical adequacy of the
free energy principle as well as its
practical utility for the study of key
biological properties such as
homeostasis and robustness depend on the
validity of those foundations
here we begin to fill this gap
so that's kind of one of their
contextualizing claims
and their aim
and one of their
arguments
a claim about their arguments is that as
we are going to argue the foundations
and physics concepts allow models built
from the free energy principle to
achieve maximum generality but these
assumptions also decrease the ability of
these models to include enough factors
to provide biologically plausible
representations of the causal networks
responsible for living systems dynamic
equilibrium
any thoughts on the aims or we can
continue
wait i can't hear you
i think that the aims are good sorry i
just realized i was muted um i think
that the these are good aims i think
that uh one of the fundamental
um
claims is that in order to make the fep
more general generalizable it's not
as specific to biology as it could be i
think that that was like the key
trade-off maybe
yes between specificity and utility and
generalizability so
one mindset is that as we generalize
we're going to be explaining more
systems different systems explaining
them better doing more and it's just all
up up with generalization
another contrasting opinion is that as
we generalize we out of necessity
abstract or average out over particulars
and so we might actually lose utility or
potentially
and even disastrously
lose the specifics of the system that
we're talking about so all of a sudden
we have this free floating
generalization or abstraction that maybe
initially was inspired by wanting to
explain some sort of key biological
property
like homeostasis and robustness in the
author's view but then we end up sort of
um
throwing out
the kernel or the essence of what we
wanted to explain because we generalized
too much so
we'll be exploring that
okay do you want to read the abstract
sure
according to the free energy principle
life is an inevitable and immersion
property of any ergotic random dynamical
system at non-equilibrium steady state
that possesses a markov blanket first in
2013.
formulating a principle for the life
sciences in terms of concepts from
statistical physics such as random
dynamical system
non-equilibrium steady state and
ergodicity places substantial
constraints on the theoretical and
empirical study of biological systems
thus far however the physics foundations
of the free energy principle have
received hardly any attention here we
start to fill this gap and analyze some
of the challenges raised by applications
of statistical physics from modeling
biological targets
based on our analysis we conclude that
model building grounded in the free
energy principle exacerbates a trade-off
between generality and realism because
of a fundamental mismatch between its
physics assumptions and the properties
of actual biological targets
cool
and
there's a lot to say that's just the
opening
salvo from the authors
how do they make good on this abstract
we can look at the roadmap
there's not too many sections in this
paper but there's a lot of uh meat
within
there's a general introduction and then
a specific introduction to the free
energy principle which is described in
the context of self-organizing
dissipative systems
and then there's a little discussion on
the explanatory scope of the fep
and the introduction of the winged
snowflake
thought experiment or idea which we'll
return to soon
section 3 talks about biological systems
as random dynamical systems which isn't
something that fep invented it's not
something that active invented this is a
broader question about how to model
biological systems and dynamical systems
section 4 models biological active
states as random dynamical attractors
and talks about three big physics ideas
that if we take section three you know
if we want to be modeling biological
systems as dynamical systems then
we're using this physics ontology and
what other key terms are relevant in
physics for discussing random dynamical
systems and we will go through them
they are the idea of phase spaces in
biology
ergodicity
and random dynamical attractors there's
then a discussion and a short conclusion
so that's kind of the overall
roadmap that's where we're going to go
we're going to be exploring that
trade-off or the implications
of the introduction of
physics fundamentals
into the generalization of biological
systems and maybe even non-living
systems as well and just
how's it all going to come together and
how does it influence how we research
going forward
the key words
are
fep free energy principle
dynamic equilibrium
homeostasis
phase base
ergodicity and attractor
and we can ask where's active inference
not that it has to be a keyword for
everything but
as we
discuss let's keep in mind what are the
differences between fep
and active and what are the implications
of
these claims about fep for active
all right how about the first keyword
dynamic equilibrium
so interestingly like you um said that
you like how this paper brings together
physics and chemistry and biology and i
thought that chemistry was kind of
blatantly omitted
and in my heart i'm a chemist like if i
hadn't studied neuro i would have really
like gone into ocum i just thought that
like working in the lab was a little
scary like too much ether and two like
whoa when i came out um
so so really uh when i look up dynamic
equilibrium or the context that i'm
familiar with dynamic equilibrium is in
chemistry and so a dynamic
equilibrium occurs when you have a
reversible chemical reaction so it's not
that the
reaction is over right like here's an
example of water um ionizing into
hydroxide and um protons right
and so
you you it's not that when you have the
equilibrium that the reaction is still
occurring it's just occurring at equal
rates in the forward and reverse
directions
so this is dynamic equilibrium and it
only happens in a reversible chemical
reaction like so so there's no other way
that i know of that dynamic equilibrium
um happens it is an example of a system
particularly a chemical system at a
steady state and so i looked through the
paper i don't know if you want to flip
to the next slide
um i looked to the paper and i i looked
like well how are the authors using
dynamic equilibrium
and i found this um phrase which i'll
say here the core of this account is a
free energy principle
um according to which all biological
systems actively maintain a dynamic
equilibrium with their environment by
minimizing their free energy which
enables them to avoid a rapid decay into
an inert state of thermodynamic
equilibrium and so then there's some
citations first in and the ramstead 2018
paper and par and first in in 2019 and
so even i looked back through these
papers and looked for dynamic
equilibrium and it's not there
in the references that i was able to
find and so i was curious what the
authors meant
by dynamic equilibrium in a living
system i mean as far as i know um like
maybe they meant dynamic coupling
between the organism organism and the
niche
or maybe they mean the non-equilibrium
steady state of homeostasis which is not
a dynamic equilibrium it's it's a
non-equilibrium so i just found this
this phrasing kind of curious um
and i'm assuming just based on context
that they're referring to homeostasis
but homeostasis includes plenty of
irreversible reactions irreversible
chemical reactions and so that's kind of
why this was a little bit
it makes sense like if we think about
instead of the water ionizing and the h
plus and the oh minus coming back
together and the overall values on both
sides are staying the same so let's
think in the biological case like moment
to moment our our mass is staying the
same let's just say or some people might
maintain the same mass for 30 years
but
underlying that stability is actually
many many
you know synthesis of fatty acids and
the breakdown of fatty acids and so it's
like okay i get it that they're both
going both sides at the same rate so
there's a stable point
but then also it's constituting its own
irreversible thermodynamic
reactions sometimes and so it's a good
question
do
fristen at all use the term dynamic
equilibrium
and are we talking about dynamic
couplings which might be at steady
states or are we talking about the
non-equilibrium steady state of
homeostasis
okay
brings us to homeostasis
sure so homeostasis is the steady state
of
internal internal physical and chemical
conditions that are maintained by living
systems and there's a lot of variables
that are can be included in here uh mass
i think actually changes at night like
the the carbon that you exhale like you
actually weigh less in the morning from
like sleeping on my face and like
emitting carbon i heard um i don't know
if that's really true but i guess it
depends on what scale you're measuring
um but but i think that ph has to be the
same or within like a pretty defined
range um osmolarity sodium potassium and
calcium ions blood sugar
body temperature is a huge one
so and and we act we do things
throughout the day like eat and drink
and use the restroom and put on jackets
to maintain to help with our you know
homeostatic conditions um internally
well unless we're eating at night we're
losing water and some other molecules so
definitely we're lighter in the morning
and then one discussion that we've had
in a few different
streams is
when do we think of homeostasis as
reducing uncertainty from a set point
like sort of a desired temperature and
then we want to just reduce our
discrepancy versus when do we see
allostasis or almost like anticipatory
processes by which biological systems
actually
take excursions
qualified excursions from set points and
how do we think about that within the
broader history of cybernetics and it's
been said that um
cybernetics had some challenges with
dealing with post-homeostasis so it's
easy enough to see how a cybernetic
system seeks
a set point but then once you start
thinking what is the process by which
that set point is itself moved around
all of a sudden that challenged a lot of
historical cybernetics frameworks so
that's definitely what we're exploring
with active
let's take another dip into a physics or
a mathematical idea of a face base
so
i'll read the yellow parts or you want
to go for it
i'll read the yellow parts and then
you'd give any description so in a phase
space every degree of freedom or
parameter of the system is represented
as an axis of a multi-dimensional space
so like every point on this spiral has
two variables that describe it it's like
its value on the x and value on the y
and then
the phase space trajectory represents
the set of states compatible with
starting from one particular initial
condition located in the full phase
space that represents the set of states
compatible with starting from any
initial condition
so just a quick comment or a thought on
that so even just in the maintenance of
homeostasis like where your you know
osmolarity is the same and your blood
glucose is the same or just
intracellular glucose or atp levels or
you know if you just want to look at at
just maintaining homeostasis not even
including like
the potential possible actions that i
could take in like moving in a
three-dimensional environment or
anything like that but but it it becomes
very quickly an expansive
multi-dimensional space like something
that we're not even like here we have
like a 3d ish visualization but you know
in all these dimensions it becomes very
um very quickly computationally
intractable because of the
dimensionality that of options that
we're presented with and just even to
maintain a homeostatic set point is is
intense
yes
base spaces are just kind of the
descriptive it's literally just the
space that something can happen in
and then there are trajectories through
face space well there's points which
just are static values like three comma
four and then there are trajectories
which are like linkages amongst sets of
points
and then also
out there in phase space are attractors
so in the field of dynamical systems
in a tractor is a set of states in the
phase space
towards which a system tends to evolve
for a wide variety of starting
conditions of the system
system values that close enough to the
attractor values remain close even if
slightly disturbed so a kind of mental
model there is like
a rubber sheet and someone pulls the
middle down a little bit that is now an
attractor because things are from near
or far are attracted towards it and then
if they're at the bottom of that well
they're going to resist being moved away
from it
and so that's sort of a simple ball
rolling into a bowl attractor state and
there's simple equations that govern
that type of movement but in higher
dimensional
phase spaces there are
different
geometries of attractors
and then also for biological systems
it
is a challenge to model using attractors
but that's what this paper is really
about can we use that model of an
attractor to talk about biological
systems and how they regulate
okay so yeah and i i just pulled this
image out actually i think it was
brought up in the t in the paper and i
don't remember if the original author
who outlined these four types of
attractor if that was kaufman i think i
feel like it was kaufman but it was
cited in this paper as well about the
four different kinds of attractors and
so that's what's shown here is the
strange attractor the point detractor
the cycle and the taurus um so just in
case you were wondering what those kind
of attractors looks like it's it's a
drawn to points in this kind of way
it is also on
another phase space of attractors
with its own x and y axis
okay
ergodicity
so this is a quote from the paper then
blue any thoughts would be cool
the ergotic density is an invariant
probability measure that can be
interpreted as the probability of
finding the target system m in any state
x when observed at a random point in
time first in 2012.
the assumption of ergodicity is
important to get the fep off the ground
since it ensures that organisms can be
modeled as having invariant
characteristics over time
so just to kind of relate ergodicity to
the phase space
so the concept of ergodicity is in a
potential phase space
that all of the potential points in that
space are visited at one point or
another like that is ergonomicity and
then the probability that you can find a
uh
the system in that space or it at that
point in space corresponds to how much
time the system spends at that point in
that space if that makes sense it's kind
of a circular loop but
this is just one slide we're gonna
return to ergodicity later on but this
is um
a topic that blue and i like learning
about however if you know more about
this it would be great to have your
perspective as well as if you're also
just learning it and have questions to
bring because
there's a lot you could learn about
ergodicity and the ergotic hierarchy so
take a dive and then let us know how the
water is
also getting fep off the ground i'm
thinking does fep start on the ground
does it start underground does it start
is it a snowflake with wings
has it always been that way
so
right exactly it's like the water cycle
okay so
on to the fep which is of course the
target the system of interest of this
paper and in active livestream 14 and
before then after then we've had a lot
of discussions what is the fvp how does
it relate to active inference and
it seems like we'll be working on those
questions for a long long time but a few
pieces that we've pulled out as kind of
being good
um sort of
cues
to bring up alongside free energy
principle and just see them as like
cousins or in a network together
multi-scale systems
ensembles like the collective behavior
of multiple particles or other
system subunits
the nexus of information and
thermodynamics which is really like
information
thermo like heat and dynamics dynamical
systems often thermo and dynamics aren't
really separated but we're getting at
that delineation
and then
action policy selection as variational
bayesian inference so using information
dynamics to study how policies are
selected
and then
they're sort of fep as it is today and
then there's where could we go and
develop with this framework which is
what we'll be exploring today
any general comments before we get into
the paper
uh only that you know you we haven't
thermodynamics has classically been one
word so like i'm starting to just use
info dynamics as one word just to be
like non-discriminatory you know or just
dynamics it's like it's all information
it's all thermo so yes exactly
okay here we go to the paper
this is the first paragraph of the paper
and it's very informative
life scientists use the term equilibrium
in various ways and so we're going to
look at three different definitions of
equilibrium
and this is one reason why it's
important to have ontologies and have
ways of using terms that we can if not
distinguish at least be clear about in
their use so
sometimes life scientists
use equilibrium to refer to an inner
state of death where the flow of matter
and energy through a biological system
stops and the system reaches a life less
state of thermodynamic equilibrium
that's sort of the ultimate equilibrium
then there's
more often they use it to mean
homeostasis which is the ability of
keeping some variable in a system
constant or within a specific range of
values
going back to these old citations for
where the term actually arises from
and so that's sort of a living system so
there's parts of it that are consuming
energy hence not at the ultimate
equilibrium but there's also other
elements of it at least over certain
time scales that are invariant
some other time
the term equilibrium is associated with
the concept of robustness which refers
to the capacity of systems to
dynamically preserve their
characteristic structural and functional
stability amid perturbations due to
environmental change internal noise or
genetic variation so it's sort of like a
low bar a medium bar and a high bar of
equilibrium ranging from just yeah the
molecules are not doing any motion
and there's a carcass on the ground two
the molecules are churning
and there's something invariant about
the living system
going up into even the idea of
robustness which is that the system is
doing something to maintain
its sort of equilibrium like its balance
amidst noise which is
maybe seen as a type of homeostasis but
not exactly the same so any thoughts on
why um these distinctions are matter are
mattering or why start the paper this
way
you know i'm curious daniel like i i
mean we've been in the life sciences for
20 some years more maybe um and i've
only used equilibrium in terms of life
sciences in the first way to like as
death um so i'm just curious and perhaps
this is the the inner chemist in me but
but are you familiar with all of these
uses of equilibrium and the life
scientists in the life sciences also
i think i've
seen the second one people might not
call it equilibrium but like a buffer
equilibrium well the carbonate and the
co2 in your blood and it's maintaining a
buffered a ph equilibrium
so that's not death it's a living system
that's doing it but it's referring to
some chemical process that's being kept
at a dynamic equilibrium
within the scaffold that a living
biological system is providing
and um
i'd also be curious i don't think we
dove into it this kitano 2004
like
homeostasis to keep something within a
range of values it sounds a lot like
robustness so how are the how are the
second and the third definitions
different because like anti-fragility is
something different where perturbations
actually strengthen the system or cause
it to develop for example but robustness
is a little bit more like homeostasis
but
open to anyone's thoughts we'll see
now
on to
fristen at all
so
over the past 20 years is giving us some
historical context
since the new millennium
theoretical neuroscientist carl fristen
and collaborators have developed an
account of the conditions of possibility
of a certain kind of dynamic equilibrium
between a biological system and its
environment
the core of this account is a free
energy principle according to which all
biological systems actively maintain a
dynamic equilibrium with their
environment by minimizing their free
energy
through inference in action
which enables them to avoid a rapid
decay into an inert state of
thermodynamic equilibrium
so here's a few of the citations 2012 13
rams said at all 2018
par and first in 2019 so here are the
papes
if people want to dive into the
references those are always really good
places to start
but whether you take the authors at
their uh manifold dimensionally reduced
word or you go into these original
papers or you know you send a tweet to
an author or you come in a live stream
and talk to them
what are the key claims of the fep
from a rhetoric perspective what does
the fep assume and what does it claim
which papers
are key to fep
not what was important in 2005 from 2002
but today what is important so how do we
respect that different citations from
the past
might have a partial picture or use a
different formalism
and then which papers are contradictory
even if only temporary so somebody might
make a claim in a 2010 paper you can't
explain situation x and then like you
know two weeks later first in it all
write the response
and then
some people have uh they bought the
rumor but they haven't heard the news
so how do you
keep a coherent narrative of the
literature
as there are
errors contradictions disc concordances
all kinds of things that just make it
less easy than it could be to understand
what is happening with fep its
proponents and its detractors
um so just a thought on this and
something that i was thinking about as i
was reading the paper and a lot of this
is footnoted throughout the paper but
the fbp like has evolved over the last
20 years so it didn't start off like in
the state that it is now it didn't start
off like a completely elaborated um
theory
and so it would be really cool to
develop a timeline of the fep like first
concept you know 2006 or whatever and
then
at what point in time did like the
markov blanket come into play and then
when did active inference separate from
the fep and and to kind of get like a
good idea of this situation as it's gone
through it's several iterations now
great idea blue i hope that in actin
flab and other groups we could
collaborate to really make that happen
because to have the timeline of
developments
and cross-link that with the core terms
which we'll talk about later today and
then also
just who was involved and what were the
contributions it would just make it
tremendously easier instead of just
going back to square one sort of a
scholar search just when we're curious
about hey has there been something
written about free energy and x
okay so that was sort of the neutral
context or
at least not so
barbarous
but
here's where the authors uh bring in the
the gap the free energy differential in
the literature and their contribution
what actions are they going to take to
reduce the differential
the free energy principle has received a
lot of attention
no citations from who a lot relative to
what
it's not i'm not saying it's incorrect
in the paper just it would be awesome to
learn
what does it look like to have a lot of
attention what does a google trends
or a book engram viewer search results
in
are we on the up or are we going down
from some period of time so what
attention what regime of attention has
the fep received and from whom
but
the foundations of fep in statistical
physics and dynamical systems theory
have not been probed yet
that's a claim maybe some people will
think that they have so we'll look
forward to learning about that
this lack of attention is unfortunate
because two reasons one the theoretical
adequacy of the fep
and two its practical utility for the
study of biological properties
depend on the validity of the
foundations so it's like we want the
house to be beautiful and useful
and if the foundations are not strong it
will not be beautiful and or useful
so this work of the paper as well as all
the work around it is related to that
gap
so a few big questions like what does it
mean for a principal fep
and
we can of course
have some subtlety with like what's a
principle a framework a theory a
hypothesis so let's just
kind of roll with it together what does
it mean for a scientific principle to
have foundations in
statistical physics what does it mean
for it to be grounded in dynamical
systems
why does that matter why does it matter
how it's grounded or who thinks it's
grounded in what
for the fep and in general
and then always trying to connect the
generalities with the minute particulars
what does this paper actually do
and then what work is still needed
because it's easy to get caught up in
some of these big sweeping
multi-decade
many person
research trajectories and it's helpful
sometimes to just separate out what is
the paper doing and then what is the
bigger picture like the grand synthesis
that has to be done between fep and some
other field
anything here
okay
here's from a footnote
and it's um
to forestall any confusion okay great
all my confusions are about to be
forestalled i love footnotes like that
our focus is on free energy theorists
not principalists by the way theorists
assumptions that all biological systems
at any scale can be modeled within the
framework of ergodic random dynamical
systems and that homeostasis and or
robustness can be defined and studied in
terms of dynamical attractors
so i don't know if that's a assumption
of
all fep
colleagues i don't know if it's a um
rather than an assumption but rather a
consequence like there are assumptions
that people use but then actually they
have come to this claim as a consequence
not as an assumption or an ungrounded
axiom
and while our discussion should suggest
that concepts and mathematical
representations from statistical physics
and dynamical systems theory are
sometimes abused in biology
it should not suggest that those
concepts and representations have no use
so it's saying in fact you can have good
explanatory predictive
models that involve dynamical systems so
it's not saying
math and biology is hopeless
and then also this 2004 paper i thought
who do you cite for saying that you know
math
gets abused in biology so this is robert
may a famous biologist
in 2004
and this was just very interesting like
understanding the non-linear dynamics
and this was in the case of a virus and
health situation
just extracting some of the key memes
it's like we're going to have to learn
across systems we're not just going to
be able to have one default system
we need to think about multi-scale
systems
for applying
and educating in transdisciplinary
contexts like
having a understanding of viral dynamics
is going to require population and
ecological understanding as well as
protein
and then
i venture to predict that the
corresponding immunology text will
indeed look different in 20 or even 10
years time okay well we're right between
10 and 20
and maybe immunologists are starting to
go oh yeah you can't just talk about
what's in the
what's the white blood cell touching the
pathogen
there's a bigger picture there's a
society
and then what are those abuses
and they're not always easy to recognize
especially because few
have
the
expertise or the confidence or the
personal narrative that they're able to
ask questions across disciplinary
contexts so it's easy sometimes for
something to be transdisciplinary and
then like the biologists don't question
the physics and the physics don't
question the biology and
all of a sudden something is not really
getting questioned so it's totally a
great point
and this is a really important kind of
fallacy essentially where a mathematical
model is constructed with an
excruciating abundance of detail in some
aspects while other facets of the
problem are misty or vital parameters
uncertain
within a massive range
and this happens just so many places
it's unreal we made a mathematical model
of this oh well you know of course we
didn't consider other factor abc
so it's not that everything has to be a
theory of everything but
we have to recognize that extremely
partial mathematical models in
biological systems
may be less helpful than people claim
them to be and it might be better if
people pooled their efforts and worked
towards better models
any thoughts on that
just uh you know i mean i think i'm
definitely guilty of uh like i remember
back to uh mike levin's live stream when
when we were abusing physics
um
so guilty as charged sometimes
um but but it's it is important to you
know have an open dialogue and
to ask questions like if there's a
concept or something that you don't
perhaps understand maybe like you feel
like you're a beginner i mean i've
definitely felt this way like maybe i'm
just being dumb but
you know and then there's actually a
very valid question at the end of that
sentence
so if you don't understand something be
sure to ask until you do i think yep
imagine just all the times somebody has
said oh fep does that apply to living
systems and so yeah it's a done deal
well you know it's not a done deal so
the conversation is still happening
here we get to section two introduce
introducing the fep the free energy
principle fep
says that unless a biological system
minimizes its surprise it will rapidly
die
now what do those citations say
do they talk about system death or do
they talk about system persistence
more specifically fep presupposes a view
of biological systems as essentially
persisters
different authors here
and for foregrounds the conditions of
possibility for the persistence of
biological systems
so that's their top-level take on fep
and then to connect a few of the
keywords in
howie 2020 refers to a system's periodic
phase attractive dynamics so attractors
in the phase space that have periodicity
in the state space to define what it is
for a biological system to exist
howie writes biological in existence is
marked by a tendency to disperse
throughout all possible states in state
space
e.g a system ceases to exist as it
decomposes decays dissolves dissipates
or alliteratively dies
in contrast to exist is to revisit the
same states or their close neighborhoods
so this is kind of bringing together
what is life schrodinger's question ram
said it all 2018
with
dissipative systems and systems that
resist dissipation systems that have a
dynamic equilibrium what is the phase
space we're talking about
these are the big questions we're
getting at
and how does one disperse oneself
exactly
yes
and how i
think uh you heard that from somebody
earlier today
somebody was getting dispersed during a
practice talk it happens
and where's surprise come into play
not just the psychological like wow i
was surprised it was a surprise birthday
party but how do we go from attractors
and dynamical systems
to
this statistical bayesian concept of
surprise and attracting sets and
lower dimensional manifolds in
attracting sets make that make that
quote big one more time for me okay so
something i i thought was um
just unique or or maybe remarkable was
it says free energy theorists relate the
notion of entropy to the informatic
information theoretic quantity of
surprise but i think that this is done
before the free energy principle arrives
like so in information theory that's
claude shannon makes the relationship
between
information and entropy and surprise so
i don't think that that's a something
that the fep started doing
well
two themes we'll return to today and
again and again which is like
first this shouldn't be a paid versus
pape battle this isn't a battle royale
for whose hot take will reign supreme we
should be collaborating on bigger
research agendas and so clarifying the
contributions that different people have
made will help demystify and make active
inference and fep more accessible
because
which claims or which contributions were
made like 100 years ago not that that
makes it more valid but
weren't made recently but sometimes when
we only see recent citations it can be
easy to get swept up but actually the
authors of this paper do a good job of
going back to some original citations
but these are big eternal questions
here's a fun paragraph in the paper
um because it's sort of like uh i i
reformatted it slightly because it it
shows that we're in
synchronous and asynchronous discussion
with fristen at all
so here is like you know him
thinking slash saying first insane
by finding this is fristen's claim
pseudo first in claim not actually his
quote
by finding a suitable attractor in the
dynamic model life scientists would be
able to gain understandings of the
workings of dot
basically like this is the dream of
active inference that if we had
attractor phase base
all these terms coming together
then
we could just
make it work for diverse biological
systems
and then
the authors of the paper write to better
understand what this means
let's examine how such idealized models
are developed and why free energy
theorists opt to build their model
starting from concepts in physics
so this is like the dream of active
inference and physical groundings for
biological systems
and then the authors do the right thing
which is to um to steal person the
argument to investigate what its actual
strengths are
and why somebody would want to make that
argument or why this is something that
we're motivated to pursue instead of
just immediately critiquing it as like
not an important thing to want
okay all right
so
here is
in the red quote from the paper
so first in at all 2006
way long ago way way long ago asked us
to
ask us to imagine a snowflake endowed
with wings
this winged snowflake could move use its
wings as solar reflectors or fans and
exchange energy with the environment for
a much longer period than we would
expect of an inanimate piece of ice to
keep going under identical circumstance
unlike familiar snowflakes the winged
snowflake can choose actions which are
the means of by which different outcomes
are brought about in different states
the environment its wings allow the
snowflake to bring about outcomes such
as lowering its core temperature in
response to an increase in air
temperature so let's go to first in 2006
and this is figure one
so we're imagining they're sort of on
the left is like a traditional snowflake
model
they're sort of it doesn't have any
action affordances so it's just being
tossed around in
the soup and it freezes when it's cold
and then when the temperature gets below
this critical phase boundary it melts
and the system
fails to persist
so it's like you know checkpoint are we
good with systems persisting
versus dissipating this is kind of our
simple physical example a piece of ice
freezing in the sky
and melting
all right now let's imagine if the ice
froze
in a way
where it had wings
and
slightly different colored wings i
wondered what the symbolism was here
but it has these two different wings
and that allows it to engage in action
on the environment so for example if it
detects or predicts or acts as if it's
predicting that it's going to head
towards a warmer area that's like you
know lower down or something all of a
sudden it can flap a few times and get
into a colder area so here this
snowflake just falls but this one is
able to flap and stay cold
and so through action
it's able to persist longer
so
it's precluding a phase transition
from solid to liquid
through
this active
exchange with the environment so that's
like the winged snowflake model
that's kind of a nice thought experiment
from yonder to help us understand like
the steps from mere physical system
to systems that start to engage in
actions on the environment
especially those that keep persistence
of the system
anything here
okay
here's figure 3 from that same fristen
2006 paper
and this is
really an awesome figure
because it shows some concordances
between actinf even though it it's not
even really used in those terms so
that's why we need the timeline like is
active even mentioned in this paper in
it might not be actually
but we can see there's this
perception action cycle
and this is related to a few other kinds
of action perception cycles
um footnote paper incoming
we can think of this as like a bowl
and then the ball is rolling to the
bottom of the bowl it's a
image we return to again and again now
the y-axis is the free energy and so
here's the minimum possible free energy
and it's like the system starts here
there's a change in the environment
that causes a mismatch
that mismatch
can be reduced through two different
types of updates of a model
one is an action and the other is a
perception so which order happens
details details details but the idea is
like at each loop there's an
environmental change
which is then renormalized or returned
to something
through perception and action which
relates to an act of inference
how we say that the two ways that free
energy can be minimized are through
updates of the generative model like
learning or parameter updating or
through action how do we reduce supply
surprise
inference and action why reduce surprise
because if we have an optimistic
generative model we don't want to be
surprised about our model where we're
living so we act and we infer
so that we persist
any comments here
but it's just a cool like input could be
the state of chemoreceptors you know
already we're going from these sort of
physics formalisms and dynamical systems
formalisms towards just oh yeah you know
drop it it could be like chemical
biological
but
was it justified in 2006 well looking
back on it
not as much as it is justified today
and what will they say in 2033 looking
back on this so
all work in progress
okay
so this is from page six of the paper
and
won't uh
read the full quote because we've kind
of gotten at this trade-off between
utility
and accuracy and generalizability but
the big questions here are
what systems is the fep modeling or
describing where has it been used where
could it be used where shouldn't it be
used or can't it be used
how good is the fep for modeling or
describing these different systems
how good could it be and what would it
take to get it there
and then also an important question for
for those of you who are fep or active
fans and you have a challenging
conversation
take a step back and ask your colleague
what models do you prefer with similar
or different explanatory scope just what
else is out there because
it really helps ground the discussion in
what that person's understanding or
preferences are
and a lot of times people will come up
blank they'll say i'm critiquing your
unified model of perception cognition
action okay great critique away that's
what i'm doing too what do you prefer up
nothing so it helps us stay positive
with the contributions that we're making
to this field while also recognizing the
discrepancy
and that combination of recognizing
discrepancy and taking action is active
inference
you know this is funny this is like a
good contrast to the sims paper that we
just did and i feel like at the end of
the last live stream we were just
talking about like thermodynamics and
information theory and the relationship
between those two things um but i always
want to take the fvp and use it for like
non-biological systems i think i like
veer toward pan psychism more than most
people
and like i don't like that i have a hard
time with the line between
mirror active inference and adaptive
active inference or like the
evolutionary late evolutionary cover
slate whatever
uh like the you know brain is the
ultimate um source of cognition and
capable organ capable of cognition and
so like would the fvp apply to a set of
molecules in a beaker
like it doesn't have preferences did
molecules prefer to be in an equilibrium
state or how does that work out like i
want to take the fvp and use it
in systems that maybe
it's not designed for i don't know i
tend to want to go the other way
makes sense
here's that adaptive versus mirror
active inference slide from 30. good
segue perfect segway and um so here's a
question from
fep landia
what makes biological cognition special
or different
so
we're not going to go too much into it
here we talked about it in
live stream number 30 a ton
and it was just super interesting to
what extent does it matter that it can
engage in counter factuals does the
temporal depth matter
but if we're on the outside how do we
know what the temporal depth is is it
the temporal depth it acts as if
it's cognizing
where does energy dissipation come into
play
so these are big questions what is
cognition
and is there just one kind of cognition
and biological systems do a special
combination of it but it's different in
kind of
decimal point but not in the top level
like are they or are they really
different in type or is it such a great
quantitative difference that it's
different in type
big
questions here
more from the paper
active inference models are phase space
representations of biological systems
so that's like
a full stop moment this isn't what
biological systems are it's a phase
space representation of systems here
we're talking about biological systems
as
forming expectations over observable
external states and inferring policies
state action mappings that minimize the
expected free energy of those states
under a generative model in some
predefined markov decision process
by minimizing expected free energy the
modeled system would attain a
non-equilibrium steady state and so it
would maintain
in some sense a low entropy probability
distribution over its states
so what is active inference
what topics is it related to
what is it based upon
we look at that ball in the bowl
and it's easy to say well the way
that the imperative that's pushing the
system forward is that the ball wants to
be as low down as possible and it's
going to be minimizing its potential
energy that way
another story about the bowl is
the ball is going to end up or act as if
it's going to end up with the tightest
bound
through time on how far left and right
it goes now that also takes you right to
the bottom of the bowl but you didn't
have to mention that you wanted to go
down
it was just that the desire to minimize
the uncertainty
led to the bottom of the bowl in that
structure
and so
how do we think about some of these
different ways and what are the physics
metaphors
and then
an assumption from the paper an
assumption made by the active inference
models developed by free energy
theorists
is that target biological systems can be
represented as random dynamical systems
what does this assumption mean exactly
what does it mean and what are the
assumptions of active
what are the assumptions of other
frameworks
does active have the same assumptions as
other frameworks does it have fewer or
different does it have more assumptions
are there assumptions of active there
are consequences of other ideas or vice
versa
so these are just awesome questions that
the authors are raising and that their
work is like a jumping off point into
good
good i so so one question that i always
have is what if the so active inference
and the free energy principle presumably
have the same assumptions but but do
they have to
um and so that's always something i
wonder
how has active inference developed this
is a fun paragraph
active inference modeling evolves
rapidly
eats shoots leaves
as maxwell ramstad dr maxwell ramsay
helpfully reminded us in conversation
up to roughly 2012 the dynamics of
internal and active states inactive
inference models were determined through
gradient descent on variational free
energy
so let's call that phase one
before 2012.
we need a real timeline for this this is
just informal but this is why we need
the timeline
figure out if we're truly on the best
timeline
from around 2012 until
recently like 10 minutes ago or 2019
active inference models have been
equipped with algorithms for policy
selection
which evaluate the average free energy
expected under each policy so expected
free energy not just variational free
energy
in their latest work
the active inference community
have endowed their models with a
recursive expected free energy
functional which enables the models to
represent target systems higher order
counter factual beliefs
which are beliefs a system has about the
beliefs it would have as a consequence
of action so that's the deep parametric
active inference that's sophisticated
active inference that's what we spoke
about with a mental action paper sandved
smith at all
okay so those are three waves that are
important to distinguish in the
development of active inference models
because these modeling advances all seem
to make assumptions about the ergodicity
of biological systems
and the biological meaning of dynamical
attractors
the points we make in what follows may
help explain why hashtag all active
inference models thus far tend to trade
off realism for maximal generality
so they're respecting the developments
on the framework
and encompassing it summarizing it maybe
accurately maybe not
and then saying because they all make
some common assumptions
they're all victim to this trade-off of
realism for generality
or is it utility for generality which
one was it again realism utility
what are the trade-offs so what are the
waves of active inference
how does aerogenicity come into play
in these different waves
so
i know there's a lot on there but this
is really a important piece to
understand
that there's been recent developments
and um
yeah it's still in progress
okay
here um this is some technical details
that would be awesome to just
learn more from the authors or from
anyone else
who
sees this and gets excited by it
this is about some of the physics
formalizations of
noise and dynamics and phase spaces
and just
a term that i was curious about is like
a co-cycle
so it's kind of taking that idea of
returning to an attracting state and
maybe connecting it to some other ideas
like a co-cycle but
these are just
things to um
learn and discuss about
and then
this is sort of the classic bayesian
network markov blanket
is there a markov blanket that picks out
the mind
is the network of autopoetic processes
and biological systems identical to the
markov blanket of the system what is the
metaphysical status of markov blankets
and then the authors write these debates
in the metaphysics of the fep can be
left on the side since we're not
interested in metaphysics here
i thought we were having a discussion
that was meta
to physics
so
where is your metaphysics now
okay anything else there
action in the loop
given this setup free energy theorists
are interested in finding the active
states of the systems that are confined
to a bounded subset of states and remain
there indefinitely
so we want to have our internal states
be at a certain level like thinking
about our temperature being at a certain
value or anything else
and now we want to talk about the
control theory question which is what
active states
should the system engage in conditioned
on internal and sensory states
such that the internal states do remain
bounded within a subset of states
more
uh technical details if one assumes that
the dynamics of the target organism
is dynamics is ergotic
if one assumes that the dynamics of the
target organism is ergotic
it's grammatically incorrect if one
assumes that the dynamics of the target
organism are ergotic that's why you
can't read it that's that's why the
compiler failed then that's it random
dynamical attractors can be associated
with the ergodic density a
p-distribution of x given m
which is proportional to the amount of
time each state is occupied by the
organism so here's where we return to
their definition of the ergodic density
as the invariant probability measure
um there's a few other terms that i know
some listeners know about whether
they'll help us with it's another
question
but what does it mean
to talk about the
lebesgue measure of the attractor
how is that connected to dynamical
systems and entropy and
whatever this integral is calculating in
the limit of time approaching infinity
but this is kind of this thing that we
see in space and in time
like
one over space like what's the tiniest
infinitesimal space
for all space or what's the tiniest
tiniest moment for all time
so
how does that connect to
action control theory
more more on that later but here even in
this um even in this slide it raises the
question
so here it says such active internal
states in an organism and so
maybe it's the way that the diagrams are
usually drawn for active inference but i
don't ever think of active states
as internal states like there's active
states sensory states internal states
external states and i always think about
the sensory and the active states as
the on the boundary between internal and
external
so
absolutely there um are internal
external sense and action states so
what are the active internal states
there's a few ways of thinking about it
the particular states are the sense
action the blanket states and the
internal states so maybe that's what's
being referred to
or
we can well when we're talking about
mental action i guess then the active
states are internal
yes
between the past and the future
but still eternal right
like in mental action right yes
with this prince with this definition of
active states in hand
so i believe that we're now working with
the fristen ontology of the action
being not the internal states but who
knows
first in 2012 finally formulates the
principle of least action as follows
the principle of least action
the internal states of an active system
so that wouldn't be the action states
that would be the internal states of a
system with on the interface having
action
they minimize supprisal l
such that the
variation delta s of action s
with respect to its internal states
r of t
existing in r vanishes and then classic
future fristen look at that the 2100s
are going to be just so good
the fep would suffice to derive the
principle of least action and is defined
by fristen in the past and the future as
follows
the free energy principle
technical technical technical if the
internal states minimize free energy
then the system conforms to the
principle of least action and is an
active system
this will be good to unpack and learn
more from the authors as well as from
those who studied these areas because
it's sort of something we all ask is
like wait least action but then they're
engaging in action couldn't they just do
less action wouldn't that be more of a
fulfillment of the least action
principle but
what is it actually it's like a
stationary principle it's an invariant
so there's a little bit more nuance than
just staying on the couch
and i haven't heard this term active
system before i've heard like active
inference system or inactive system but
this active system is is new to me and
indeed fristen was a very forward
thinking guy
uh he is a very forward-thinking guy all
the way into the 2100s
um
when expressed in these terms so in the
terms of physics the fep provides us
with an account of biological
persistence as a generic type of
stability
of random dynamical systems
so then they talk about first in 2012
and 13 some simulations
and then here's what the author's
challenge is and say let's then put into
better focus some of the difficulties
involved in this challenge and ask
is there any reason to believe that all
biological systems at any scale can be
modeled as random dynamical systems
and how does this maximal generality
bear on the degree of realism of the
models
so we had a few previous discussions ago
we had um we had realism we had utility
we had instrumentalism we had all these
different axes and how are we going to
manage that trade-off because sometimes
the most quote realistic description of
a system isn't the most useful or it's
not the most general so there's a lot of
trade-offs happening
how does model realism relate to
generalizability and how does that
relate to the utility of the model as
well as other attributes like its
simplicity
that's like the relationship between the
map and the territory if you wanted the
territory then you wouldn't need a map
yeah
and then almost like the compass
um or a piece of paper that just you
know says like you are here it's like
it's so general you can always break
down and that map is going to be
at least not telling a lie
you know this is your left or something
like that this is
but
is that useful
it generalizes really well but have we
lost this whole question of navigation
in the desire to find the simplest map
so something that that i wonder about
like um you know our biological systems
random dynamical systems like what's a
non-random dynamical system like a
dynamical system as opposed to
like a static system like statics
dynamics and so like what other system
could
a biological system b
like if it if it's not a random
dynamical system what is the alternate
of a hypothesis just like what you said
about like okay well what is the better
model for cognition if not you know
active inference then what model
is the better model right like so but
what about for a biological system if
it's not random dynamical system
what is the best model for a biological
system
yes
dynamical through time dynamics random
used in a lot of different ways but is
that
statistical is it stochastic where is
determinism fit into play
well let's talk about it so here's
section four and this is like some of
the main
body paragraphs and contributions of the
paper it's the section modeling
biological active states as random
dynamical attractors
free energy theorists account of
biological systems persistence relies on
three main modeling assumptions
ergodicity
the existence of markov blankets that
imply a partition of states into
external and internal
the existence of random dynamical
attractors
in this section we concentrate on
assumptions one and three and on the
more fundamental challenge of defining
phase bases for target biological
systems in the life sciences so
the three core ideas
that they're saying are
underlying fep work in biological
systems are ergodicity markov blankets
and random dynamical attractors
are those the main three that's a really
important question
this paper is going to focus on the
first and the third
not going as much into the markov
blanket discussion because there's been
a huge amount of
discussion on markov blankets and we've
talked about them severally so
they're going to focus on ergodicity and
random dynamical attractors
that's 4.2 and 3 but that's going to be
introduced by a discussion on phase
spaces in biology so that's what the
authors have set out to do
now
um shameless lab plug
we're working on an active inference
ontology in a participatory way that
includes references
definitions
translations into multiple human
languages it will be many things and it
will scaffold educational content that
will make this entire field more
accessible and rigorous so
terms like face space
um we've talked about we talked about
state space on september 13th
so every week
we're bringing together different
perspectives and sharing resources and
working towards common understandings in
this document
to really get at what are the core
assumptions of fep or active what do
these terms mean what would somebody
need to learn if they wanted to
understand more so it's really important
work and we're definitely going to draw
upon the author's contributions here
as we work to scaffold an active
inference ontology so that we don't get
tied up in active state action state
systems with action we can be clear
about how we're talking about this field
and in fact we really have to be
anything on our ontology document before
we continue back to the paper
okay
but this has been a fun project with
many contributors
so let's talk about phase spaces in
biology
we introduced this in the earlier
keyword section
so the phase space the system is a giant
space formed by the relevant degrees of
freedom of the target system
and then
that's the space of the possible
a point in the phase space
corresponds to microstate
which completely determines the system
in terms of the variables and parameters
required for analyzing its dynamics and
the dynamics are determined by the
equations of motion which describe the
evolution of points or trajectories in
phase space
so here's that phase-based kind of model
and then the authors are going to
suggest that there's
at least three facts
cold hard facts that make face spaces in
biology hard to apply
because first biological systems have
many degrees of freedom it's not just a
pendulum
second the symmetries
which are invariant preserving
transformations
underlying the observed regularities in
biological phenomena are more unstable
than physics
okay
and third the phase space for many real
world biological targets is much less
stable than that for the kinds of target
systems studied in physics
so what do you think about that or about
phase spaces in biology
yeah i mean i think i mentioned the
multi-dimensionality in the beginning
when we were talking about the phase
spaces in biological systems
um and i think that it just comes to
that with any
um with any system right like you can
always include too many parameters like
you can have the territory or you can
have a dramatically reduced map and so
finding that that correct balance is
hard and if we're looking at um
you know say states of a system and
trying to predict the next state
um
what
are all of the factors conditionally
independent is there some you know
mingling of the variables there and is
it okay to just model a couple at a time
and what if we don't know if there are
some confounding variables in the system
too so it's it's a difficult task but
it's how do we start to get a grip on it
as hard yes
and a big question in the background
here is
does this matter for applications so yes
these are in principle critiques of
doing dynamical phase space models of
biology
but we know that dynamical systems
models of neural systems of
hormonal systems
ecology these are all really useful and
people use them every day so gene
regulatory networks don't forget those
how could we forget but does something
having these sort of fundamental
critiques
prevent it from being useful not always
this is a really nice um
points about the open-endedness of
biological phase space
so this is the work of longo montvale
and kaufman 2012
who said that in physics one can
pre-state the phase space for target
systems based upon stable stable
invariances and symmetries
so we can like say the ball is going to
be rolling around in the box those are
the boundaries and here's the
invariances
historical processes
studied in evolutionary and population
biology
like all these processes that we know
and love in biology
involves symmetry breaking which makes
the phase spaces structurally unstable
ever-changing and unpredictable
now unpredictable is a little bit of a
tough one because that's a continuum
what if you can predict one percent of
the variance in great evolutionary
transitions is it unpredictable or is it
predictable you know is it half full or
half empty
and then this is from the paper
because we cannot pre-state
the ever-changing phase base of
biological evolution we have no settled
relations by which we can write down the
equations of motion
of the ever new biologically relevant
observables and parameters
but that we cannot pre-state
more we cannot pre-state the adaptive
niche as a boundary condition so could
not integrate the equations of motion
even were we to have them all so it's
like there's the ball rolling around on
the billiards table but now there's
mutations in the genome of the ball so
that there's like totally new mechanisms
arising in a way that might have a
historiosity
oh yeah and the table is mutating and
it's made up of other organisms so it's
easy to see how we get lost in the
complexity
yet adaptive action exists and useful
models exist so how do we reconcile the
fundamental open-endedness and
creativity and novelty of evolution with
our desire to explain some portion of
the variance so we can act effectively
well and this relates like to a question
that i had brought up to you um
yesterday daniel i think about like what
about discretizing space and so i know
that like some of the physics principles
rely on infinite time like the
ergodicity specifically relies on the
possibility of infinite time and this is
all stuff that's like kind of beyond me
but but what if we have a temporarily
restricted moment right like what if
we're just interested about now and five
years from now or what if we're just
interested in now and five years ago
right and and so
in each moment is this symmetry breaking
happening or at what scale and so is
there perhaps a chunk of time a small
discrete chunk of time from you know a
microsecond to 100 years
where
these types of um inferences can be used
and where the equations are applicable
and where we can use the model with
under the you know specification that
this model is not good for the next two
million years but it will last you 20.
right like so it's a model of the phase
space of blood glucose versus ph
in a person
as measured by the devices we have it's
not of blood sugar over a million years
because that doesn't even make sense
given the system of interest so how do
we reconcile pragmatics and utility with
these really important philosophical
questions so that was four one face
spaces
word two
ergodicity
one of the assumptions of the fep is
that all biological systems are ergodic
so
paging
ramstead at all at all
this is something we really want to
unpack and understand like
how how does it
mean
ergodicity or more precisely metric
transitivity in random dynamical systems
like what is the math and the physics
and is that an assumption of the fep
what does this mean to assume that
biological systems quote are ergotic
which is different than saying
biological systems for some spatial
temporal scales can be modeled using
statistics that involve
ergotic assumptions
so there's a lot of nuance there like
whether we're making realist claims
about how biological systems are
or whether we're using statistics in an
instrumental fashion to make useful
um
models of organisms but the big
questions are like what kinds of systems
are ergodic and how
what are the implications of ergotic
assumption is it ever not an assumption
but it's actually like a consequence of
some empirical grounding
there's the ergotic hierarchy so
ergodicity it's not just like yes or no
there's a total continuum with a lot of
complex math
and then just
for everyone
how or where does this matter
for modeling under the fep or active
inference in real world situations
and they did call out in the paper um a
reference to ramstead and the local
ergodicity which is you know for a
biological organism i'm like something
like the you know boundaries in which
the organism can exist
um anyway i think uh maxwell come come
explain it to us please but um
the authors did mention that so
here's a quote from the paper
bierkoff 1931
demonstrated that if a dynamical system
is ergotic then the infinite time limit
exists and coincides with the phase
average for almost all initial
conditions little x like the realized
conditions within the bigger x like the
space of the possible
this is called the ergodic theorem
and that is going to get linked to
everything we were just discussing
surprisal minimization as ergodicity
maintenance
and then here the proof of the principle
of least action
is straightforward
okay
and rests on noting
that action
and the entropy of the ergodic density
over external states are related via the
ergodic theorem firsten past and the
future
so
pnas
burkhoff 1931
pretty interesting paper and just
it's amazing to think like how in 100
years of mathematics after this but this
is kind of that initial formulization of
what if the space average and the time
average were going to be
related to each other
so it's a cool topic we've brought up
ergodicity before and it would be really
helpful for people who know some of the
technical details to help
work with it
this is one um analogous to how they
brought up like here's the facts that
challenge phase spaces in biology so
here's some facts that challenge the
application of ergotic theorems to real
systems
and there's good reasons the authors say
to think that the theorem cannot be
realistically applied in the domain of
biology so
first off it's not enough to show
that
the infinite limit exists it also has to
be shown that the convergence rate is
plausible we're going to talk about that
in a second
second point comparing biological to
non-biological systems
it's harder to estimate the amount of
time
that they need to kind of asymptote
because of the non-uniformities
another reason and this is going to be
one that i know people will have things
to say
why ergodicity cannot plausibly be
assumed in biology
is that the ergotic theorem requires the
dynamics of the system to be ergotic
which means that eventually
almost every point will visit every
measurable region in x
we've talked about that before like but
biological systems never revisit the
exact same state if you think about
every molecule constituting the phase
space but if the phase base is just
temperature versus blood sugar
yes you pretty much will revisit some
points but will you revisit every point
are you going to reach a value of
negative 5 000 sugar and 900 degrees
celsius no
we're talking about bounded states
and
that's kind of a nuance
and then well and also it's also the
arrow of time is is moving forward right
it points one direction and so like you
know at age 40 my skin will never have
the collagen it had at age four like
that's never going to happen again right
so i mean and there are some things that
just decrease as you age
yes
so there are yeah
let's look at this palacios 2018 paper
so this is
i guess an earlier paper by the first
author so it kind of gives a little
context
had we but world enough and time
but we don't
exclamation point
colon
justifying the thermodynamic and
infinite hyphen time limits in
statistical mechanics
great title well punctuated uh a bevy of
punctuations and this is just a very
interesting paper that we skimmed over
and i'm sure there's a ton to say it'd
be great to
speak with the author about it but
they argue that this has there's an
important consequence for the
philosophical literature on infinite
limits
and that's basically it's not just about
like where you are
that's where you are in face space it's
about where you're going that's the
asymptote in infinite time
and it also matters how fast you're
going to get there
so it's like kind of the asymptote for a
pane of glass
is like in a puddle on the ground
because it's a liquid or it's a glass
but that might take
so long
that over some time scale it can be
modeled as if it's not changing for
example
so that's kind of a cool notion that
it's not just about
where a system is or where it's being
attracted towards but actually the
dynamics of the approach matter a lot
and that's certainly true in biological
systems
um the assumption of erodicity to give a
definition of equilibrium states is a
controversial assumption even in the
domain of physics especially due to
existence of physical systems in
equilibrium that have proven to be
non-ergotic so i didn't find this
palacios 21 citation in the biblio
this is the reason why physicists and
philosophers have offered alternative
approaches to equilibrium that do not
rely on erica d
even philosophers that defend a
quasi-ergodic approach to equilibrium
recognize that this definition of
equilibrium may plausibly apply only to
a restricted class of systems such as
gases
so
sounds
bad
but then we go okay
the authors say it doesn't mean of
course that ergodicity or a weaker
notion of local ergodicity may sometimes
be a reasonable assumption to make
so in other words it might be useful
for specifically defined systems anyway
however the fact that one cannot
extrapolate the assumption of ergodicity
to the behavior of all relevant systems
in biology cast doubt on the project of
formulating a principle that depends on
this assumption
and is both maximally general and
biologically realistic
so ideas that we've heard a little bit
about but how are we going to finesse
realism
and
generality
and grounding in physics when biological
systems might be grounded and things
that
are not fulfilled
so that's 4.2
all right
4-3 random dynamical attractors
what makes the application of fep to
account for real-world behavior
biological systems
is even more challenging beyond 4.2 and
4.1
because one also has to show the
existence of an attractor
and also justify
why certain attractors but not others
plausibly denote homeostatic states in
the target
there might be multiple attractors
and then there's this question of
chaotic systems do you want to add
anything on these
basically it's non-trivial to say that
there's an attractor and it's the right
one and it results in adaptive behavior
there's a lot that goes into it
so
but
we can learn more we'll hear more
questions later and then just to go
quickly to five and six
so five discussion
in the previous sections we've analyzed
three challenges involved in the
justification of the free energy
principle
so one was pre-stated phase spaces
for most biological systems
two
was the lack of the warrant
for making ergodicity assumptions in
biology
and three is the challenge of
identifying homeostasis
with attractors in a phase space even if
one and two were accomplished
based on our analysis
one overall conclusion is that
because of a fundamental mismatch
between its physics assumptions and the
properties of biological targets
model building grounded in the fep
achieves maximal generality
yay
for minimal biological plausibility
bat
so
how is that going to work
as we raised earlier
how
does generality versus plausibility get
traded off for real systems
in the fvp
in active and in what other frameworks
let's always have another one if people
want to or can think of one so that
we're not just asking whether it's like
as good as it could be because here's a
hint it's not as good as it could be
we're always going to see ways to
improve the theory
and the literature if only by organizing
other work and making it more accessible
so
what is its relative biological
plausibility what is its relative
generalizability and what are we
relativizing too
because as they say
like for other idealized scientific
representations even if the fep involves
simplifying distortions it does not
follow
that it must be minimally realistic and
have limited explanatory or predictive
power
so they're saying like it's kind of like
enemy my enemy is my friend it's like
saying just because you idealize and
simplify
that it doesn't mean that you're gonna
get explanation or prediction
so
that's their discussion
they
fall back to the three key points
that they think challenge
the usage of physics ideas in biology
that are postulated to be underlying the
fep phase spaces erikaticity and random
attractors
and they're concluding that there's a
mismatch between the physics assumptions
and the properties of biological targets
here in the implications and predictions
they write
if the fep or active inference models it
grounds
make simplifying distortions
distorting assumptions about the phase
space of a target system the ergodicity
of biological systems and the existence
of an attracting set corresponding to
homeostatic states for these systems
then these idealizations should earn
their keep so you know
you've been a bad theory but
it's not all over you could be a good
theory you could earn your keep maybe in
the future
and then they um write
um
these idealizations should allow life
scientists to attractively draw some
explanation and prediction about
relevant biological observables in real
world systems and assess those
predictions against measurements
relevant to understanding some aspect of
homeostatic processes in actual
biological systems
decosta at all 2020.
our contention is that the idealizations
made by free energy theorists do not
play these practical and epistemic roles
and so this is the de costa at all 2020
active inference on discrete state
spaces a synthesis
and um
here are from table one here's all the
applications
so it's interesting because like this
pragmatic and epistemic
role that's kind of the ontology of
active inference that's how we talk
about policy selection
and then it's like
okay looking at this list i'm seeing a
lot of pragmatic and epistemic value
but
what is the contention
that the idealizations themself
do not play pragmatic or epistemically
valuable roles
i think it'd be good to get a little
clarification because table one has a
lot of and since then even
there's a lot of interesting areas what
do you think about that blue
yeah it's interesting like the word
choice of the author here like the
idealizations made by the
free energy theorists theorists so what
are these idealizations like the
reliance on ergodicity and random
dynamical systems theory like are these
idealizations or is it actually using
the fep and active inference for
practical applications that don't play
the practical and epistemic roles so i
just i'm curious as to that word choice
and steven in the chat wrote the use of
approximation science around ergodicity
could give the potential to have
sufficient revisiting of states to make
meaningfulness plausible
how can we measure when sufficient
approximation to erodicity exists in
order to make variational free energy
inferences
so good question we can ask and as we
kind of explored revisitation is one
component of ergodicity but also there's
this element of
re of revisiting every point and of
exploring the whole phase space so
as we kind of addressed what is
the reality of arrogancity and applying
those models to biological systems and
then yeah can we use approximations and
approximation science to make it work
even if in the infinite perfect case
it doesn't exactly seem like it would
like the t-test assumes that there's an
equal variance between the two groups
unless you have a t-test within equal
variances
yet
no two groups in reality are going to
have the exact same variance yet the
t-test works
so how can we take that same approach
and think about the systems that we're
working with here
here's their whole conclusion
in a churning mail storm
they're arguing that fep theorists have
pursued maximal generalization
by relying on physics concepts
however that means that they've
sacrificed biological realism
and the danger of sacrificing biological
realism is that you risk
minimizing explanatory and predictive
power
of those accounts
for biological systems which are
homeostatic and
manifestingly far from equilibrium in
their persistence
and their last paragraph
the fep can perhaps be better understood
as a maximally general definition of any
system that persists
but this definition does not seem to
provide us with any new insight into
biological systems
to the extent free energy theorists
treat all biological systems at any
scale as pre-specific pre-specified
generic objects with fixed
currently unknown equations of motion
their account risks missing all features
that make biological systems interesting
kinds of thermodynamic systems so it's
like you know a city where there's all
kinds of intersections and then you have
a grid map and so we distort the system
in a way where all of a sudden we
thought we were generalizing but we
ended up losing touch with the system
and therefore explanatory and predictive
power
any thoughts on the conclusion
um no i mean i think that that
you know they have made their point
pretty clearly so um
i think the fep also has a lot of room
to grow being that it's
you know relatively not not quite 20 yet
so i think that um you know hopefully
that
some
pragmatic and epistemic value will be
put forth by
um the generalizations made by the fep
in some future model perhaps
that's almost like a deep time
sociological value
even a provocative theory which has
limited epistemic or pragmatic value not
saying the fpp is could play a role in a
broader social system
that still gets the job done so that's
kind of a cool notion
what questions for 31.1
did you put up
so i think i raised them all already so
like what is the dynamic equilibrium of
living systems as the authors state here
and as i stated in the beginning
keywords
and it says we should pay closer
attention to the fundamental differences
between physics and biology like what
are the differences between physics and
biology like in the paper they made
they went to a great length to explain
like why biological systems weren't
ergotic but then also like they made the
point that
physics they have they have a really
hard time like proving ergonomy exists
at all um in any physical system so so
what are what are these fundamental
differences between physics and biology
that that are so critical like that it
seems that you know the fep kind of
misses the point
um and then they refer often in the
paper to active states as as internal
states and i i just wonder
what like i mean i've really thought
about active states as like the
interface between internal and external
and part of the blanket and so i just
wonder why
the active states are included in
internal states and their you know
description of the model so so just some
some technical things that i have
questions about and um you know
hopefully the authors will be here to
answer them cool
stephen wrote
we may never know the whole phase space
as the phase space may be variable yes
that's what we talked about like the
phase base of temperature does that
include
impossible temperatures that the system
cannot persist at and then the fact that
the phase space can change is the
open-endedness
of the um the longo i think 2012
open-endedness of the phase space in
biological systems so for sure that's
why we can read the papes and then have
specific citations and ontologies in
mind so we're not kind of cross angling
because those are great points and they
were the points made in the paper
and then stephen asks is biological
realism based upon folk biological
assumptions
so i think this sort of like folk
hyphenated everything has come into the
forefront with the discussion with matt
sims
so yeah
what is
biologically real
you know what models are biologically
realistic isn't that just like the
question of what is real
so yeah what is even real at all exactly
yeah realism sounds good until you
so you ask too many questions
so
what a fun discussion
so we ask all these questions like
what does a good understanding enable
what are the unique predictions and
implications of this paper
what are the next steps for fep and
active
what are the goals of this research
and then what are we still curious about
it was a
fun discussion so thanks a ton blue for
doing it and for working a ton on the
slides
we'll look forward to
31.1 and beyond
awesome thanks bye
bye